so before you all make the comment down
below yes i am an architect
that cannot freehand draw
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about the
fundamental basics that you need to
understand
if you want to be an architect or if you
want to draw like an architect
today we're talking about the four most
important
pages that you will ever and i literally
mean ever
present to any client at the very start
so the first and most important plan
is the site plan the site plan consists
of some highly critical information
that needs to be on there not only for
you but also the client and the builder
so the first and most important element
is the boundary lines
these lines indicate to the builder to
the client and to everybody
participating in the process
where the building is actually going to
be located on that site
by doing this we're able to understand
how far from each boundary line
where we need to set it out and then
move on to further elements
such as landscaping and if we
potentially even want to incorporate
that landscaping
into the design itself we then go on to
driveways to elements such as
the lot itself how big it is and of
course
last but not least the north point it is
one of the most critical elements of the
design
now like i talked briefly through that
diagrammatical sketch there
it is very important that this site plan
is accurately represented
no none of these colors none of these
line weights are correct
none of this information that is being
presented is actually
used in an architectural presentation it
is more so for presentation purposes
of this youtube video only so don't go
out drawing your buildings in blue your
setbacks in red and all sorts of things
like that
it is literally just me having a quick
sketch having a quick play
to really be able to convey this
information as best as i possibly can to
all you guys out there watching
and i don't mean to be sexist in any way
shape or form but it is literally
98 percent of my audience is male if for
the two percent of females watching
hello and thank you so much
if you're working backwards for example
with the site plan and the site plan was
already populated with contours
landscaping
rocks and all sorts of bits and pieces
in the way you would actually
use that north point that is one of the
most critical elements at the start to
define
where your building is going to be
located and how you're going to
orientate it
because by orientating your building the
correct way you're going to maximize
all the solar passive principles that
you will learn throughout your
architectural career
moving on to the next plan that's
critical and it is the floor plan it is
one of the most
important elements of any design because
obviously
it tells your client where areas of the
building are going to go
it tells the build of this information
but most importantly it allows you to
massage and play with these spaces to
really understand
where they're going to go something that
is critical that is often forgotten is
dimensions so make sure you showcase
dimensions your elevations and your
sections in the building as well
oh scene change that's right we haven't
had a scene change on this channel
since i ruptured my achilles a couple
months back so you've been a member of
the channel for that long
thank you so much for continuing to
follow me along this journey
but we continue to talk about floor
plans here and we continue to talk about
their importance
and how critical they are to the design
if you're able to annotate your floor
plans correctly
you're able to position your bedrooms
for example to allow the person to wake
up with the sunrise or
to go to sleep with the sunset depending
on what type of person they are
if they work night shift for example
they definitely do not want a master
bedroom
that is directly facing the sunrise for
us that is in the east
which means you want to position the
bedrooms all the way to the back
south corner if you're in the southern
hemisphere if you're in the northern
hemisphere that's obviously flipped it
goes to the northern side because of the
way the sun is positioned
the same principle applies to living
areas and living spaces
you really want to position them to the
north if you're in the southern
hemisphere and the south in the northern
hemisphere
to be able to let as much natural light
into that building throughout the day
by allowing this natural light to come
in during the day
then all of a sudden the whole house is
heated and warmed naturally and you can
control solar passive design a lot
better
when you stick your bedrooms at the
front and your living spaces at the back
it's going to be cold inside that living
space
all day every day whilst your bedrooms
are going to be extremely extremely hot
so understanding why the floor plan is
there why it is so
important is definitely one thing that
you should master and
learn all sorts of different
configurations understanding that
configurations are endless and
it doesn't matter how long you've spent
in the profession you will never
redesign the same floor plan again if
you're starting from scratch without any
material to bias
your new design on elevations come next
in the drawing
order and they are critically important
because they dictate materiality
and the whole ideology of the design
you're able to get a look and feel of
what that building is going to look like
where the windows are going to go are
there going to be stackable sliders
is there going to be any articulated
timber features and feature screening
where the glass is going to go what kind
of glass you're using
what materials and so on it then becomes
important to annotate all of these items
off the side
so anybody looking at it doesn't just
have scribbles on a line
we can annotate absolutely anything and
then move backwards and forwards between
this design
to try and then periodically enhance it
and create it even
better design at the end of the day so
for example if we wanted to go back and
change the timber blades into timber
bifolds we could simply go back
re-annotate it and change the keynote to
actually
depict what we're trying to say no all
these plants don't belong
next to the couch randomly spaced
throughout the living room they are
literally only here to create the scene
however we're talking about elevations
in this scene here today
and why elevations are so important as
part of your four
critical drawings that you showcase to
any client at any given time
elevations are all about talking about
the language of the architecture the
materiality the texture
the detail it's all about understanding
what this building is going to look like
and where things are going to go
so for example if you have a down pipe
that's going to run smack bang down the
middle
through a glass window in front of the
front door
that's not the right place for it to go
so if you need to show down pipes you
want to show them
away from any pivotal point like this
however at the start in sketch design
when you're conveying ideas across to a
client
it is all about really conveying the
materiality and the texture so for
example
the concrete contrast with that walnut
timber bifold panels
in the sketch is a very elegant very
sophisticated look that works for many
many people
so to be able to complement the concrete
with the natural warmer colors of the
timbers it really
breaks up that harsh consistency of a
concrete box that many people are
worried about
and then if you recess that floor again
down below a cantilever the top floor
over the top
which would be depicted more in the
ground floor and first floor plans than
the elevation
but you would see some sort of shadows
coming across you can again
break up that concrete with the glass to
be able to connect that
indoor outdoor space and really give
people a true
visual representation of potentially
what that space might look like
so even though this visual aid was very
simple
and very quick to create it is something
that will definitely help individuals
who
struggle to read 2d plans to be able to
understand
what that building is going to look like
down the track also 3d visualization
programs are
hugely beneficial to you if you know how
to use them
but more often than not you don't go
ahead and give 3ds at the very start
you try and work your way through the
design to understand what they really
want before
you showcase something as magical and
time consuming as
a 3d video for example last but not
least is of course the section
this information is more so important to
the builder and to yourself designing
this process and this building
more so than the client most clients
won't really understand what's going on
here but what you're trying to actually
depict is an understanding of how thick
the walls are how thick the slab is what
kind of materiality we're using
is it a concrete floor is it a timber
floor how the sections are cut through
the ground how the ground
connects to the building and then of
course we can go into much much more
detail and understand
the makeup of the slab the thickness and
height of the internal buildings
if we're going to involve skylights
windows how that light penetrates
through into the building
and how the timber screening that we
talked about previously
implements this design we can also go
further and break down this section
and showcase sectional details which can
annotate
how the architecture actually comes
together and the finer finishes and
details when it is constructed
so that way when we do go into this
finer elements
we truly get a full architectural
understanding of what the building will
look like at the end now i'm just
genuinely running out of places and
spaces to talk to you from
but i thought i'd talk to you about
sections in a very grand void so
sections that start are designed
to create spaces and they're designed to
understand spaces
so for example if you have a grand void
like we have here in the stairwell
you can articulate this in a section by
showcasing
the difference in volumes you can't do
that in a floor plan
very well you can note void for example
but you can't actually showcase how high
the ceilings
should be in that space so at the start
of the design phase it is all about
really showcasing spaces and
understanding
volumes later down the track it is
definitely about going into detail and
construction knowledge to be able to
understand and explain to a builder how
two elements
come together and what the architectural
detail is there anyway that's all for me
today guys thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that like
button down below help this video with
the youtube algorithm
smash that subscribe button if you want
to see more of my videos
and as always i'll see you next monday